la nièce attention c'est parti je
voudrais une musique de suspense
attention celui qui fait tomber celui
qui fait tomber et frère fais attention
à tes voisins c'est bon
on peut le mettre comme on veut
pas la vérité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je la sens pas du tout histoire
attention
[Rires]
quand même attention
[Applaudissements]
on reste sur les personnes ayant une
poitrine Castaldi
es
chaud chaud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il tombe là
c'est bon le prochain des morts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à côté à côté comme ça
à côté de pas forcément sur le bail il
est en train
je rappelle Daniel Momo
[Applaudissements]
j'ai ressenti une petite émotion tu vas
ressentir mon cul tu vas voir
Maxime
tu peux le mettre à côté
[Applaudissements]
courant d'amis
vous êtes trop long
on est obligé de refaire
[Applaudissements]
allez vas-y mets les trucs on va le
refaire non merde
comme ça voilà non voilà non voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci bonne année-là elle a perdu
la femme
[Applaudissements]
va te changer mon cœur va te changer